[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the President of
the United States
[Music]
[Music]
well thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well thank you very much everybody wow
we've all been through a lot together
and we probably deserve that hand for
all of us because it's been a very
unfair situation I invited some of our
very good friends and we have limited
room but everybody wanted to come we
kept it down to a minimum and believe it
or not this is a minimum but a
tremendous thing was done over the last
number of months but really if you go
back to it over the last number of years
we had the witch hunt it started from
the day we came down the elevator myself
and our future first lady who's with us
right now
[Applause]
[Music]
and it never really stopped we've been
going through this now for over three
years it was evil it was corrupt it was
dirty cups
it was leakers and Liars
and this should never ever happen to
another president ever I don't know that
other presidents would have been able to
take it some people said no they
wouldn't have but I can tell you at a
minimum you have to focus on this
because it can get away very quickly no
matter who you have with you it can get
away very quickly it was a disgrace
had I not fired James Comey who was a
disaster by the way it's possible I
wouldn't even be standing here right now
we caught him in the act dirty cups bad
people if this happened to President
Obama a lot of people would have been in
jail for a long time already many many
years I want to start by thanking some
of and I call them friends because you
know you develop friendships and
relationships when you're in battle and
war much more so than gee let's have a
normal situation with all that we've
gone through we've done I think more
than any president and administration
and really I say for the most part
Republican Congressmen Congress women
and Republican senators we've done more
than any administration in the first few
years you look at all of the things
we've done I watched this morning as
they tried to take credit for the stock
market from
from think of that let me tell you if we
didn't win the stock market would have
crashed and the market was going up a
lot before the election because it was
looking like we had a good chance to win
and then went up tremendously from the
time we won the election till the time
we took office which was November 8th to
January 20th and that's our credit
that's all our credit and leading up to
that point was our credit because there
was hope and one of the reasons the
stock markets gone up so much in the
last few days is people think we're
doing so well they liked the State of
the Union speech
[Applause]
it really is it's a true honor to give
it and making the State of the Union
speech I was with some people that have
been around they've been all over the
world and one of them said highly
sophisticated person said you know no
matter where you go in the world it
doesn't make any difference there is
nothing like what I witness tonight the
beauty the majesty of the chamber the
power of the United States the power of
the people in this room that really an
amazing even I don't think there is
anything like that anywhere in the world
you can go to any other country you can
go to any other location any other place
it's the beauty of everything it's what
it represents and how it represents our
country I want to start by introducing
some of the people that are here I know
some are gonna be left out but they work
so hard and this is really not a news
conference it's not a speech it's not
anything it's just we're sort of it's a
celebration because we have something
that just worked out I mean it worked
out we went through hell unfairly did
nothing wrong it did nothing wrong I've
done things wrong in my life I will
admit not purposely but I've done things
wrong but this is what the end result is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we could take that home money maybe
we'll frame it it's the only good
headline I've ever had in the Washington
but every paper is the same does anybody
have those papers does anybody have them
because they're really like that so I
appreciate that but some of the people
here have been incredible warriors
they're warriors and there's nothing
from a legal standpoint this is a
political thing and every time I'd say
this is unfair let's go to court they
say so you can't go to court this is
politics and we were treated
unbelievably unfairly and you have to
understand we first went through Russia
Russia Russia it was all [ __ ] we
then went through the Muller report and
they should have come back one day later
they didn't they came back two years
later after lives were ruined after
people went bankrupt after people lost
all their money people came to
Washington to help other people
bright-eyed and bushy-tailed I say they
came one or two or three people in
particular but many people we had a
rough campaign it was nasty it was one
of the nastiest they say they say Andrew
Jackson was always the nastiest campaign
they actually said we topped it who was
a nasty it was a nasty both in the
primers and then the in the election but
you see we thought after the election
would stop but it didn't stop it just
started and tremendous corruption
tremendous corruption so we had a
campaign little did we know we were
running against some very very bad and
evil people with fake dossiers with all
of these horrible dirty cops that took
these dossiers and did bad things they
knew all about it the FISA courts should
be ashamed of themselves it's a very
tough thing and then we ended up winning
on Russia Russia Russia I should have
taken the one day as I said and it took
years then Bob Muller testified
that didn't work out so well for the
other side but they should have said
that first week because it came out is
that right Jim Jordan they knew in the
first two days actually Devon is that
right two days they knew that we were
totally innocent but they kept it going
mark they kept it going forever because
they wanted to inflict political pain on
somebody that had just won an election
that too a lot of people were surprised
I mean we had polls that said we were
gonna win we had Los Angeles Times and a
few a few papers actually said it was
we're gonna win but it was gonna be
close and we did when it was one of the
greatest wins of all time and they said
okay he won and you know I wrote this
down because that was where thing called
the insurance policy to me when I saw
the insurance policy and that was done
long before the election not what's done
when they thought that Hillary Clinton
was going to win and by the way Hillary
Clinton and the DNC paid for millions
millions of dollars to fake dossier and
now Christopher Steele admits that it's
a fake because he got sued by rich
people I should have sued them too but
when you're president
people don't like suing I want to thank
my legal team by the way not for that
advice but for
[Applause]
[Music]
you guys stand up close
[Applause]
great job
[Applause]
[Music]
right at the beginning they said sir you
have nothing to worry about all of the
facts are on your side I said you don't
understand that doesn't matter that
doesn't matter and that was really true
they made up facts a corrupt politician
named Adam Schiff made up my statement
to the Ukrainian president he brought it
out of thin air just made it up they say
he's a screenwriter a failed
screenwriter he tried to go to
unfortunately he went into politics
after them remember he said the
statement which is a mob statement don't
call me I'll call you I didn't say that
fortunately for all of us here today and
for our country
we had transcripts we had transcribers
professional transcribers then they said
oh well maybe the transcription is is
not correct but lieutenant-colonel vid
ben and his twin brother right we had
some people that really amazing but we
did everything we said what's wrong with
it well they didn't add this word or
that what didn't matter
I said add it they're probably wrong but
added so now everyone agrees that they
were perfectly accurate when you read
those transcripts Tim Scott I don't know
if Tim's here but he said sir was the
first one to call me sir I read the
transcript you did nothing wrong and
Mitch he stayed there right from the
beginning he never changed and Mitch
McConnel I want to tell you you did a
fantastic job
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
somebody said you know Mitch is quiet
guys that is that quiet they that quiet
these are the P he doesn't want people
to know him and they said is Mitch smart
I said well let's put it this way for
many many years a lot of very smart bad
in many cases sometimes good but people
have been trying to take his place and
to the best of my knowledge I've never
even heard the subject come up because
they've been wiped out so fast this guy
is great and I appreciate it Mitch and
he's also given us 191 now 191 federal
judges two Supreme Court judges her drop
to 191
great guy great guy he's a tough guy to
read I'm good at reading people tough
guy to read I'd call him my wife would
say how'd you do with Mitch I don't know
that's what makes him good when you can
read somebody fantastic job then he
understood right for this was crooked
politics this was crooked politics how
about all these people they're running
for office they're saying the worst
things about me like eight senators on
the Democrat side most of them got wiped
out you know they got their 1% or less
most have got less they decided to go
home let's go back to California let's
go back to wherever they came from let's
go back to New York how about that one
or New York senator Gillibrand let's go
back to New York after they get nothing
and then they take an oath that they
will be fair that they will be reasoning
all of the different things than they
had assigned they're not fair but here's
the beauty so we have four left they're
saying the most horrendous things if I'm
it's okay it's politics and then they're
supposed to vote on me they tried to
replace me and then they're supposed to
be voting so I think it's I mean I think
it's incredible but so Mitch I want to
thank you very much incredible and you
have some of your folks here and they're
incredible people and they've been right
from the beginning and again you're out
of session unfortunately I didn't you
know I only told these folks let's do
this today we did a prayer breakfast
this morning and I thought that was
really good in fact that was so good it
might wipe this out but by the end by
the time we finish this will wipe that
one out those statements I had I had
Nancy Pelosi sitting four seats away and
I'm saying things that a lot of people
wouldn't have said but I met them and I
met everywhere okay but we have some of
the folks that are going to be leaving
right after this and they work hard and
they did work hard bill Cassidy senator
stand up bill Beauregard
[Applause]
[Music]
great man when I need to know about
health insurance and pre-existing
conditions an individual mandates I call
Bill
or I call Barack so we get those two
guys they know more than anybody a man
who just became a Senate he's a little
bit like me we have a couple of them
very successful guy in business and he
said what the hell I'll run for the
Senate from Indiana and he ran and I saw
him on television destroying his
opponent and a debate I said you know
this guy could win and I got behind him
and Mike Braun you have done some great
job thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
a man who got James Comey to chunk and
he was just talking in his regular voice
he is the roughest man he's actually a
unbelievable and I appreciate the letter
you sent me today I just got it
but she's got this voice that scares
people you know people from Iowa can be
very tough we're doing very well in Iowa
but at a chuck Grassley he's looking to
call me well you tell me what did you
say now he wasn't being rough that was
just the way he talked and that was when
called me I think that was when Comey
announced that he was leaking lying and
everything else right he choked because
he never heard anybody talk like that
you know you should have done if I wish
you got angry you could have gotten the
whole ballgame he would have said I give
up
chuck Grassley is an incredible guy
[Music]
and a man who you know he was running
against a tough smart campaign or we
learned out how good she was right she's
a great campaigner in fact by the end of
the campaign she was actually I thought
she was more for me than you were Josh I
was worried I saw her and she was saying
the greatest things about me and you
know who I'm talking about
and I went to a great place Missouri and
I said who do you have to beat her and
they said well we have four people I
said let me see him I got an interview
can you imagine I'm interviewing people
for the United States Senate this is
what I do
where have I got but I love it I love it
because we're getting great people the
first one I met was Josh Holley after
about ten minutes I said to the people
don't show me anybody else this is the
guy he was the Attorney General did a
phenomenal job in the state highly
respected and Claire McCaskill so the
theory was you couldn't beat her great
campaign and remember the last campaign
she was gonna be taking she was always
gonna be taken out and she wins and
people say how did that happen didn't
happen with him but she got so friendly
toward me in fact one of the ads I still
have I'm putting it in the archive says
one of the best ads I've ever made and
she tried to convince people that we
were best friends but Josh ended up
winning by five or six points you are
unbelievable you were tough and you are
something and one of the greatest
supporters on the impeachment hoax was
Josh Holley he was incensed actually I
watched him he was incensed at what they
were doing and what they were saying and
those were the ones you know I had some
that said well I wish you didn't make
the call and that's okay if they need
that it's incorrect it's totally
incorrect and then you have some that
used religion as a crutch they never
used it before an article written today
never heard him use it before but today
you know it's one of those things but
you know two failed presidential
candidates so things can
happen when you fail so badly running
for president but Josh Holley I want to
thank you you were right from the
beginning men did I make a good choice
thank you tremendous future
a man who is brilliant and who actually
was deceived
to an extent comes from a great state
Utah where my poll numbers have gone
through the roof and one of the senators
poll numbers and not this one went down
big he saw that you saw that Mike but
Mike Lee is a brilliant guy he's
difficult whenever my son does you know
we do sound a lot of legislation that's
it's big and it's powerful but it's sort
of everybody has to approve it and I see
ninety nine to one ninety nine to one I
say don't tell me who's the one is it
Mike yes and he always has a good reason
for it too by the way
but he is he's incredible and right at
the beginning he knew we were right Mike
and I appreciate it very much it's just
fantastic and say a lot of the people of
Utah and tell him I'm sorry about Mitt
Romney I'm sorry okay we can say that
Mike Lee is by far the most popular
senator from the state but you've done a
fantastic job Mike I've in many ways in
many ways a young woman who I didn't
know at all but she's been so supportive
and I've had great support from other
people in that state and she's been so
supportive and she's been downright
nasty and mean about the unfairness to
the president and Kelly Lafleur I
appreciate very much thank you
she saw it very early on and we have I
don't know if we have other senators
here but we got a hell of a lot of
congressmen I'll go over them quickly
but they have they have also been you
know it helped when we won 197 to
nothing that's got to be a first Kevin
right is that like a first the
Republicans have this image see I say
Democrats are lousy politicians because
they have lousy policy open borders
sanctuary cities they have horrible
policy who the hell can win oak the new
policy is raise taxes they want to raise
taxes you know all my life I wasn't in
politics but I'd say if you're a
politician you want to say look at a
lower taxes they want to raise taxes so
they have open borders sanctuary cities
raise everybody's taxes get rid of
everybody's health care 180 million
people in the United States and they're
really happy and we're gonna give you a
health care that's going to cost more
money than the country could make in 30
years if it really does well that's one
year so I've always said they're lousy
politicians but they do two things
they're vicious and mean vicious these
people are vicious Adam Schiff is a
vicious horrible person Nancy Pelosi is
a horrible person
and she wanted to impeach a long time
ago when she said I pray for the
president I pray for the president pray
she may pray but she prays for the
opposite but I doubt she prays at all
and these are vicious people but they do
two things they stick together
historically I'm not talking now they
stick together like glue that's how they
impeached because they had whatever the
number is 220 people so they don't lose
anybody they'll be able to impeach
anybody you could be George Washington
you could have just won the war and they
say let's get him out of office and they
stuck together and they're vicious as
hell and they'll probably come back for
more but maybe not because the
Republican Party's poll numbers Mitch
have now gone
more than any time I think since 2004
2005 and you know what happened then
but in normal times decades you would
call it that was a little unusual time
it was for a very short period the
Republicans party parties poll numbers
and Donald Trump's poll numbers are the
highest I've ever had that so maybe even
wrong it's no way to get your poll
numbers up it's not worth because from
my family standpoint it's been very
unfair for my family it's been very
unfair to the country think of it a
phone call a very good phone call I know
bad phone calls it's a phone call with
many people I think Mike Pompeo was
probably on the call with Mike Mike
Pompeo was on the call and many people
were on the call I know that many people
they even have a print tie bringing up
an old favorite word of mine The
Apprentice they have a printer they have
people on these calls and I know there
are many when I speak to the head of a
nation and they have many people on I
made also note do you think they're just
in the case of Ukraine he's a new
president seems like a very nice person
by the way his whole thing was
corruption he's going to stop corruption
we even have a treaty 2001 1999 it's a
treaty side treaty that we will work
together to root out corruption in
Ukraine I probably have a legal
obligation mr. attorney to report
corruption but they don't think it's
corrupt when a son that made no money
that got thrown out of the military that
had no money at all is working for three
million dollars up front
eighty-three thousand a month and that's
only Ukraine then goes to China picks up
one and a half billion dollars I think
goes to Romania I hear and many other
countries they think that's okay because
if it is is evanka in the audience is
Eve okay well my kids could make a
fortune
I think I'd make a fortune it's corrupt
but it's not even that it's just general
corruption and the other thing is
mentioned in the call and something that
I've told Mike Pence our great vice
president I would tell him all the time
and I told him when he went on the trip
because he was over there he never
mentioned anything about this when you
had your meeting it's a terrible thing
but I tell Mike I said Mike we're giving
them money and you know you're always
torn about that because we have our
country to build we have our cities to
build and our roads to fix but we're
given them money tell me why is it
Germany paying money why isn't France
why is it United Kingdom paying money
why aren't they paying money why are we
paying the money is that a correct
statement Mike I say find out what the
hell's going on and I told that to all
of my people
OMB I said I asked a question how much
is Germany bang
why isn't Germany paying why is the
United States always the sucker because
we're a bunch of suckers
but that's turning around fast but it
makes it harder when stuff like this
happens because you want to focus and
you want to focus perfectly think what
we could have done if the same energy
was put into infrastructure prescription
drug prices think of what we could have
done and I'm now talking both sides
think of what we could have done if we
had the same genius because it's genius
I will say it's genius on the other side
maybe even more so because they took
nothing and brought me to a final vote
of impeachment that's a very ugly word
to me it's a very dark word very ugly
they took nothing they took a phone call
that was a totally appropriate call I
call it a perfect cork as it was and
they brought me to the final stages of
impeachment but now we have that
gorgeous word I never thought a word
would sound so good it's called total
acquittal
so
[Music]
so I want to if I could real fast just
introduce a few other people I have to
start with I have to start with Kevin
man did you do a job
lucky you there lucky you're there
because wouldn't it worked out if you
don't have the right people I'd say
Kevin McCarthy has done an incredible
job
[Music]
and he loves his job and he loves this
country tell you what Mitch and Kevin
they love what they do
now Mitch wouldn't even tell you he
liked it
hey Mitch do you like it no matter no
it's she's the greatest poker player
right Kevin was I loved it right and I
will say that you're gonna be Speaker of
the House because of this impeachment
hoax and I'm gonna work hard on it I'm
gonna try and get out to those from
those Trump areas that we won by a lot
then you know in 18 we didn't win we
just won two seats in North Carolina two
wonderful seats in North Carolina that
were not supposed to be won but I went
and I made speeches and we had rallies
and we did a great job and we wondered
we took two seats nobody writes about
that if we lost them it would have been
the biggest story of the year but we're
gonna go we're gonna do a job and we're
gonna win a lot of seats we're gonna win
a lot of seats people are very angry
that Nancy Pelosi and all of these guys
I mean Nadler I know I'm much of my life
he's fought me in New York for 25 years
I always beat him and I had to beat him
another time and I'll probably have to
beat him again because if they find that
I happen to walk across the street and
maybe go against the light or something
let's impeach him so we'll probably have
to do it again because these people have
done stone cold crazy but I've beaten
them all my life and I'll beat them
again if I have to but what they're
doing is very
so Kevin McCarthy has been great so a
few names right and they'll be if you
forget if you want you can raise and
I'll say great love to have you
wonderful but we're gonna do the best we
can and I have my cabinet but my
cabinets differ and I appoint them okay
I didn't see all of them helping so much
you know they were running their their
various bureaucracies right now my
cabinet is great and they're all here
but today is the day to celebrate these
great warriors right these are great
warriors they really fought hard for us
and so I'll start Kelley Armstrong North
Dakota Kelley thank you great job great
job
Jim banks of Indiana Andy Biggs where's
Andy boy oh boy
Andy weekend there's a guy he's tough I
hear we're doing well in Arizona huh
it's going good yeah I think so I think
I saw polled it was very good for me I
think we have to make sure Martha's
gonna do I think Martha's gonna do good
but we have some states that are gonna
be not easy but Arizona's been great and
we're stopping illegal aliens from
coming in we're putting up walls New
Mexico to a state that's never been in
play for Republicans he's totally in
play right Nevada is really looking good
we're doing well we're doing well we're
gonna have a great there's more spirit I
will say this there's more spirit now
for the Republican Party by far than the
Democrats you know Mike Pence just got
back from a place a beautiful place that
Chuck Grassley knows well Iowa and he
was talking about this fiasco the
Democrats they can't count some simple
votes and yet they want to take over
your health care system think of that no
think of it but we also had an election
out there and we got 98% of the vote we
have two people running you know I guess
they consider them non people but they
aren't running I mean one was a governor
one was a congressman they're running
who got 98 percent of the vote and
everybody from the media was saying who
those crowds over there you know they
expect it to be one of these competitive
where everybody's running because they
want to win they want to win and it was
Trump right mark Meadows whose Trump
this was a trip crowd and a lot of
actually a lot of my guys went there
they went to Iowa and a lot of friends
went there and we had tremendous they
say the spirit the spirit for the
Republican Party right now is stronger I
think than it's ever been in the history
of our country
I think it's spoiled in itself and that
includes Honest Abe Lincoln and a lot of
people forget Abe Lincoln I wish you
were here I'd give him one hell of an
introduction but he was he was a
Republican nation Abe Lincoln Honest Abe
Bradley burned Alabama what a great
place activating a man who has been an
unbelievable friend of mine and
spokesman and somebody that that I
really like and I know Kelly you're
gonna end up liking him a lot
something's gonna happen this could be
very good I don't know I haven't figured
it out yet but Doug Collins where is he
where's Doug you have been so good thank
you very much
thank you very much
thank you really amazing job a young man
who is born with a great gene because I
know his father and how great a
politician it was but he's from Florida
sometimes controversial but actually
he's not controversial he's solid as a
rock and he's a friend of mine Matt
Gaetz Matt thank you Matt that's a great
job
all right this guy so he's the NCAA
meaning a couple of years ago when he
was in college wrestling champion and
CAA that's the big deal that means in
all of college you're the champ
you're the best his record was
ridiculous
nobody would nobody could be at him and
I see it you know every time I see him
when I first got to know him Jim Jordan
when I first got to know Jim I said yeah
he never wears a jacket the hell's going
he's obviously very proud of his body
and they say where he works out you know
with the congressmen senators they work
if they say when Jim works out even
though he's not as young as he was but
they we works out the machine starts
burning there's just a different form of
a workout than us write something and
there he is look at that guy but one day
I'm looking and it looks tough and I'm
looking and I'm looking at those ears
and they say those ears have something
going on there I said did you ever
wrestle yeah I did but he doesn't talk
but I checked this guy was a world if
this guy was a champion top top wrestler
and when I had the top I had all of the
teams and by the way your Super Bowl
champions are coming I think next week
or soon very soon and they every one of
them want to be here and the coach loves
us the coaches great Andy Reid and every
one of them want to be here we have
people loved it but we had all of the
NCAA championship teams here they had
the golf the basketball that they had
every team here and one of the teams was
wrestling the wrestling team was that
Penn State and Penn State won the title
they have a great team and I walked up
with Jim and it's like I didn't exist
those wrestlers they grabbed him they
loved Jim Jordan and we love you too
because you are some warrior
a woman who became a so we have a couple
of women's that became stars you too and
I always liked the name of her you know
I like the name let's go I liked it
that's how I picked it I like the name I
saw that face I saw that everything they
gave me cards yet like seven opponents
right and you have no idea how much the
public appreciates how smart how sharp
you are this I can't tell
can't tell they just said you know she's
really good she's really talent and I
said let's go we worked with her she won
her race tough race it's no longer tough
because what she does out there is is
incredible
Arizona loves her but you were so
incredible representing I don't see me
representing our country and getting it
out of this impeachment hoax what you
did was incredible so Debbie please
stand up Debbie Lesko
man who I became very friendly with I
don't know why you ever have where how
that's the media certain people call you
take their calls other people call if
they don't have information they won't
take anybody's call but other people
call and you don't this is a guy he just
is just a very special guy his wife I
actually like better than him to be
honest because he doesn't know that I
know that he didn't actually support me
right from the beginning but she did and
on my worst day right uh my worst day my
worst I won't tell you why it was my
worst but it was not one of those good
days she got on a bus got many other
buses and women all over North Carolina
and they toured North Carolina well mark
was back sort of semi supporting another
candidate which he ended up leaving very
quickly I don't think you had a choice
because of your wife but thank her and
Mark Meadows he's an extraordinary guy I
mean the only problem is I guess he's
announcing he'd only win by 40 points
but he's announcing that he'll be not
running this time you have somebody good
to run somebody gonna win your district
by at least 20 points please okay but
he's a tremendously talented man not
just as a politician as a human being
he's incredible and and during these
horrible times I mean the way he worked
and Jim and all of you guys the way they
worked was so it was like their life was
at stake so many Rhonda Sanchez is
another one he worked so hard then he
called me he said sir I'd like to run
for governor he said governor I don't
want you to run I like you staying you
know I want to run for governor and I
said well if you have to I'd like your
support I said how can I support you
you're at three he was at three he had
no money somebody else was at 38 and
they had 22 million cash right I said
look if it's important I'll do it
because he's he's been another great
warrior and he's by the way he ran I
endorsed him his numbers went through
the roof
the man who we beat who is expected to
win easily called me after the race he
said you endorsed him and it was like a
nuclear bomb went off there was nothing
I could do he never even spent his money
he saved it but Ron de santis is another
one and now he's the governor of Florida
and by the way he's a great governor
he's a very popular governor his numbers
are in the 70s and he's done a great job
but mark I want to thank you very much
fantastic job thank you very much mark
better
and Mike Johnson of Louisiana where's my
central casting what a job you can
represent me anytime you can represent
me any time thank you
what a job you've done thank you Mike
and a man nobody's ever heard of except
the other side he's the other side's
worst nightmare
this guy goes down into dungeons and
basements he'll find a document no
matter what he's the most legitimate
human being he's the hardest worker he's
unbelievable
he took tremendous abuse I mean abuse
the the media and you know the other
side and the bad ones the leakers the
liars the dirty cops they wanted to
destroy him they tried they got close
but he wouldn't let it happen and
honestly in a certain way he was the
first one when you say Jim and Mark and
ever this was the first guy came out of
nowhere he's saying these people are
corrupt he's still saying it and he was
unbelievable Devin Nunez
[Music]
that's so true Devin he'd come in and
say I didn't even know him I just heard
they were like there was this
congressman who kept going into a
basement into files he knew something
was wrong you felt it right and now we
know a lot more than we knew then right
you never thought it was as bad as it is
and hopefully we're gonna take care of
things because we can never ever allow
this to happen again Scott Perry of
Pennsylvania Scott thank you thank you
Scott really great and you're doing very
well over there by the way just so your
numbers a man who is a I mean central
casting if I'm gonna pick Perry Mason
I'm gonna do a remake of Perry Mason
other than bill Barr I picked this guy
but I have to say I picked ball I pick
bar first right John Ratliff right but I
have to tell you if we're doing a remake
of Perry Mason the man I get there's
nobody in Hollywood like this John
Ratliff right so such a great lawyer
incredible guy credible talent but just
a great lawyer that we appreciate it he
gets on that screen and everyone says I
agree the other side folds up so fast
we'll probably be using a lot of you in
the next year but you have been
fantastic Jen we appreciate it thank you
very much a man who's braver than me and
braver than all of us in this room he
got he got wet he got whacked my Steve
right
I went to the hospital with our great
first lady that night right honey and we
saw a man that was not gonna make it he
was not gonna make it he was the doctor
and I told him his wife I said she loves
you why do you say that because she was
devastated a lot of wives wouldn't give
a damn a lot of a lot of wives a lot of
wives what I said yeah I said how's he
doing
oh she couldn't even talk to you was
inconsolable most of us would say not
good listen I'm going home right but the
doctor came in the wife is like she was
a total mess she was really devastated
and it really looked like he had a 20 25
percent chance I think you said a record
for blood loss and Steve Scalise I
actually honestly I think you're better
looking now you're more handsome now you
you weren't that good looking you look
good now he looks better now can you
believe it I don't know what the hell
that is
better now
what a guy
and he was practicing he was practicing
for the baseball game against I guess
the Democrats right
and this whack job started shooting hurt
Rogers I don't know if Rogers here but
hurt a number of people hit him but
really hit Steve he Steve was at second
base he was the second baseman and he
went down and and it was terrible I mean
I saw the whole thing and it was
terrible fortunately you had two brave
policemen with you because of your high
position and Congress you had two
policemen and they were amazing the man
and the woman and they came and they
didn't have rifles they were against
supposedly pretty good sharpshooter with
rifles good equipment and all they had
was a gun and they started coming in
from the outfield shooting and it's so
far away that a handgun is not preferred
this guy has the rifle and he's hitting
people and he was going to move up and
there was no out I mean if he would have
been able to move up there was no way to
get out the entrance was a single
entrance way on the other side way he
was so everyone went into the dugout ran
into the dugout but Steve was really hit
badly in the stomach and with a bullet
that rips you apart it was supposed to
do that it was rips it rips you apart
and these two people came charging
forward bomb bomb bomb and one of them
you know who one of them him got the
shooter hit him and then got him killed
him from long distance it was amazing if
he didn't have those two people you can
imagine right you could imagine what
would happen so Milania and I went to
the hospital that night and he was in
such bad shape and he's been working
ever since so hard but six months ago
they had a baseball game at the
Nationals Park and I'm watching and it's
its own television and it's just you
know game people you want to win it
right and Steve's at second base the
poor guy can't even walk
do you remember Bobby Richardson for the
New York Yankees he was known for range
Louie range he had the greatest range of
a balls hit the shortstop Bobby
Richardson's the second player second
basement Bobby Richardson would field
the ball if it's it the first base he'll
throw it at a first baseman he had
unbelievable range this was not Steve
Scalise Steve had no range one foot Hin
he has to fall down right because you
know he was trying to get better I don't
know who to help put you or the field
and this is a true story so the game
starts and the first pitch Steve sin is
second base and the guy is really in bad
shape
and I said this is terrible a shot
ground ball shot is hit to second and
Steve I say I didn't have time to think
too much but I said this is not good
that ball was going toward him and this
guy stopped that ball caught the ball
he's now laying down he throws the ball
the first base he gets about I said it's
the most incredible thing I've never
seen that letter I've never seen
anything like
right
and he gets him out and they then took
him out of the game which was a very
wise thing because you could never do
that again in a million years but you
aren't gonna let that ball go through I
don't care if was hit by the greatest of
all time right that ball was not going
through you because you are a warrior
Steve is fantastic you are fantastic you
and Liz and Kevin what a great what a
group I mean what a group I got lucky I
got lucky because you need the right
people if I had the wrong people there
may be a different story maybe we'd be
celebrating something else but I really
want to thank you steve scalise and at
least you I just read the story she's
most incredible what's going on with you
Elyse
so I even said you know I was up
campaigning for helping her but I
thought she looks good she looks like
good talent but did I not realize when
she opens that mouth you at killing them
Elyse
I lace and there's a big story in the
New York Post I love the New York bus
because they treat me well there aren't
too many of you that do but today you're
treating me well I even had a great
headline I New York Times Washington
Post I had all these great headlines
maybe we should just end it right there
but you had the greatest story yesterday
in the post the people from all over the
country are contributing to her campaign
they were so enthralled with the way you
handled yourself what you said the way
you said it and I'll always be your
friend I think it was it's really an
amazing story what a great future you
have what a great future thank you first
lady agrees by the first lady agree and
Michael Turner you can represent me any
time where's Michael where is he
well you can represent me how good were
you is another there's another Perry
Mason type I think right what do you
think John but Michael you were
fantastic and we appreciate it
bread Wenstrup whiz bread
great it's a big day for Lou you notice
only the lawyers state they all the
lawyers stayed behind
Lee's Alton how good are you how good
and loo your name's not down that he'd
give me a name do you know if I didn't
announce Louie whoever the hell made
this list I gotta get rid of because if
I wouldn't have pronounced Louie it
might have been the end of the
presidency Louie you have been so great
so tough and so smart I think I did it I
got it but Louie has been amazing he's a
tough guy he's a smart guy he streetwise
like crazy we love Texas and we're with
you all the way Louie
we're with you all the way thank you
very much so so that's the story we have
a great group of warriors and there are
others left and I guess probably I'm
sure I didn't mention a few and I
apologize if that's the case
how's he packed really good my man stand
up please we yeah he's the one who said
you should run right Matt said it's like
five years ago six years ago and I made
a speech and then they do some kind of a
straw poll who made the best speech and
he said I made the best speech with all
these professional I hate to say this
with all these professional politicians
they voted by far the best speech was
Trump he calls me says you should run
for politics I say what do I know about
politics but you know what we learned
quickly and our country has never done
better than it's doing right now but
thank you Matt great Taylor
so so that's the story we've been
treated very unfairly fortunately we
have great men and women that came to
our defense if we didn't this would have
been a horrific incident for our country
when you have Lisa and Peter the lovers
the FBI lovers
I want to believe the path you threw out
for deputy director Andrew McCabe that's
the office there's no way he gets
elected meaning me there's no way he
gets elected this is Peter
to Lisa it's probably trying to impress
her for obvious reasons there's no way
he gets elected but I'm afraid we can't
take the risk now think of this in other
words if I get elected they can't they
two lowlifes they can't take their us
they can't take their eyes think of it
and that's where it came up the greatest
word of all insurance policy so he says
but I'm afraid we can't take the risk
she may lose it's like an insurance
policy in the unlikely event you die
before you're 40 in other words if I won
they were going to do exactly what they
did to us they were going to try and
overthrow the government of the United
States a duly elected president and if I
didn't fire James Comey we would have
never found this stuff because when I
fired that sleazebag all hell broke out
they were ratting on each other they
were running for the hills let's see
what happens let's see what happens it's
in the hands of some very talented
people we're gonna have to see what
happens but I can tell you in my opinion
these are the crookedest most dishonest
dirtiest people I've ever seen
they said this is struck god
hillarie should win 100 million to one
this is about me this is an agent from
the FBI look how they let her off 33,000
emails deleted nothing happens to her
nothing happens it's unbelievable but
think of that god
Hillary should win when these guys are
investigating Hillary then they go to
work for Muller the two of them and when
Muller found out that everybody knew
that they were 100% this way he let them
go but they deleted all of their emails
and text messages so when we got the
phone they were all deleted could you
imagine the treasure trove they
illegally deleted so they left they left
a bob muller he had to look but he
didn't have a lot of other things always
had to look you mr. g-man and I love the
FBI and the FBI loves me ninety nine
percent it was the top scum and the FBI
people don't like the top scum so think
of that 100 million to one and he's
investigating me
and then God Trump is a loathsome human
being isn't he
these are the people looking at me I'm
really not a bad person and paid [ __ ]
yes he's awful how would you like to
have that this is just this is the good
stuff this stuff a hundred times worse
than that these are all dirty people and
now I just heard that they're suing the
United States of America because they
were too feared with talking to let it
happen just not gonna let it happen we
cannot let this happen to our country
so I'm gonna leave now and I don't know
if any of you have anything to say you
could say it but this is sort of a day
of celebration because we went through
hell and I'm sure that Pelosi and crying
Chuck telling this guy all the time the
only time I ever saw him cry was when it
was appropriate known him for a long
time crying Chuck but I'm sure they'll
try and cook up other things they'll go
through this state of New York they'll
go through other places they'll do
whatever they can because instead of
wanting to heal our country and fix our
country all they want to do in my
opinion it's almost like they want to
destroy our country we can't let it
happen Jim Jordan did you want to say
something go ahead mark
this was a highly partisan situation
Pelosi said I copied it down exactly
before the impeachment she want to
impeach from day one by the way don't
let it fool you you know she said no the
impeachment is a very serious thing I
said she wants to impeach watch
impeachment is so divisive to the
country that unless there's something so
compelling and so overwhelming and
bipartisan bipartisan it was 197 to
nothing and other than one failed
presidential candidate and I call that
half a vote because he actually voted
for us on the other one but we had one
failed presidential candidate that's the
only half of vote we lost so we had
almost 53 to nothing
we had 197 to nothing and the only one
that voted against was a guy that can't
stand the fact that he ran one of the
worst campaigns in the history of the
presidency but she said there's
something so compare has to be so
compelling and so overwhelming and
bipartisan I don't think we should go
down that path because it divides the
country suits right about that and it's
just not worth it
that was Nancy Pelosi a year ago right
and I think it's a shame I think it's a
shame but as I said if we can put this
genius to work on roads and highways and
bridges and all of the things we can do
prescription drugs you know we had
secretary azores here and I want to
thank him for this but we had first time
in 51 years where drug prices actually
came down last year first time in 51
years but what we can do working with
both parties in Congress is would be
unbelievable it'd be unbelievable we can
do and I know Chuck Grassley is working
very hard on it and Mitch is working
very hard but what we can do is is
incredible what we can do just generally
we've done so much without it we've
rebuilt our military
we've cut regulations at a level that
nobody thought possible will always
protect our Second Amendment we all know
that but I just want to tell you that
it's an honor to be with you all I want
to apologize to my family for having
them have to go through a phoney rotten
deal by some very evil and sick people
and de vacas here and my my sons and my
whole family and that includes Baron
that includes Baron he's up there as a
young boy stand up honey thank you honey
[Music]
[Music]
so I just want to thank my family for
sticking through it this was not part of
the deal I was gonna run for president
and if I won I was gonna do a great job
I didn't know that I was gonna run and
then when I got in I was gonna have to
run again and again and again every week
at a run again that wasn't the deal but
they stuck with me and I'm so glad I did
it because we are making progress and
doing things for our great people that
everybody said couldn't be done our
country is thriving our country is just
respected again and it's an honor to be
with the people in this room thank you
very much everybody thank you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well we just go outside
[Music]
fair enough
[Music]
I think that any vaccine going to be
several years away at the earliest hi my
name is Vanessa raba
I'm an assistant professor in infectious
diseases at NYU and I work on emerging
viruses and vaccines most vaccines take
several years to develop so it takes a
lot of effort by a lot of people to make
a vaccine so we don't need the actual
whole live virus strain to make a
vaccine because scientists in China have
already character